thank you everyone for coming to this
session today I hope we're gonna get to
talk a bit about how many virtual
productivity experiences and I wanted to
explain a little bit why I set up this
panel and okay let's wait a second so
you know we flowing in and out okay so
the whole idea of productivity in VR on
a yard and the way I thought of this
panel is that when I think about
productivity I think that this is
something that happens in a while it
happens while we're on our work and you
know many people work in offices but
many people work in so many other areas
and all these areas they're barely zero
digitally type of or you know you'll
have a digital footprint but it's not as
strong so the one thing that happens in
productivity is that it happens in
awhile and the other thing is that it
needs high fidelity because we need time
sensitive spatial sensitive type of
systems and ok it's really this flow of
people it's kind of ok so the other
thing is that I sort of a spatial
computing and how brittle reality and
augmented reality are part of these new
spatial computing devices and I thought
ok well a special computing can also
happen in the wild because you can have
things around you and it also needs high
fidelity and it may be that spatial
computing is actually the most optimal
type of computing for productivity so
then I thought ok well we're gonna do
productivity and we will need devices
from the wild and for me that looks like
wearable technology
and when I look at this I feel like the
content is inside the screen is not
around me so this is gonna change and
it's gonna change with the spatial
computing so the moment you're wearing
these wearables you can start having
digital content around you and
collaborate in a very different way with
the content it's interesting because
inside only one device here you can
render all the other rest so and here we
have this small device that can own each
of one of the other ones and render them
inside and that's the it's kind of also
solving a different problem which is
this challenge of society of devices
that we have in productivity so if you
wanna have computing in all the areas
that I was showing you know from the
real lonely wild you need the devices to
talk to each other and if you only have
one device it's very easy to talk
between each other because you're
rendering everything through this one
device that it's hierarchical No
so I wanted to also show a different
project because when we think of how
many temporal reality were very much
focused on the visual perspective of it
and but there are many other ways to
explore reality and I also like this one
because if you think of wearing
something on the wild and walking around
and for example wearing a head-mounted
display all the way from home to the bus
station
you're basically blind so I like this
soundscape up because it's for blind
people to navigate in the real world
it's already in four countries a lot of
people are using it and this is what it
looks for you so to go from one place to
another and I imagine if you were in a
virtual reality moving across the space
something similar could enable you to be
in both realities at the same time time
that tells you we are pointing at
building 34 okay now of course we can't
walk there's a road
the way that's alright so let's walk
along the road and find a place to turn
right okay alright let's go you can hear
the beacon on your right yeah walk along
here so I know that I'll have to at some
point turn right
that's right good
it says aim so right there you have that
point in which is telling you what's
around you and I think the that's a very
key challenge of spatial computing is
that you'll have a reality on top of
your reality very much like there could
be a Pokemon goal just here I just don't
know about it so all these devices will
need to interface with that digital
content and that digital content will
need to also interface with the reality
and that's how you will achieve a bigger
scenarios for productivity and I want to
go just one moment
back to the first display here and and
talk for a second about this because so
once we have a spatial digital content
around any of these scenarios you can
keep working in your real life while
having the digital content so it's not
anymore about having a substitution or
an entertainment type of perspective we
can do entertaining two hours a day we
work eight hours a day so that's kind of
how I see it and Microsoft is doing a
big effort on the first line worker but
I see how all these other aspects could
be also tackled and and now I want to
introduce the rest of the panelists and
I think each of them will talk a bit on
different aspects of the topic we're
gonna have Henry folks talking about
wearables how can we have this wearable
computing that goes with us and help us
in the productivity environment we're
gonna see a bunch of projects that we
have known here at Microsoft Research
with the Yale
and some of them are on the wild and
then we're gonna talk about the fidelity
aspect we need this very high fidelity
in order to perform things at the level
we need in a Productivity setting so
we're gonna have Henry first thank your
first yes okay Thank You Mari
so it's yes Andy you don't like this
contrast but I want to see the people I
think this is good we could train yes we
could turn the lights in front off a
little bit but the lights on you and I
want to keep on so can we turn the
lights off me in front please
yeah yeah I just but I want to keep the
lights on people here because I came to
talk to you the you know the visual is
not that important okay we're ready
something will happen let there be light
and there was light
no no no okay fine it's already done
thank you thank you for inviting me and
it's so nice to see old friends here and
since you none of you sit in front I'm
gonna come and talk to you here okay
what I want to talk to you about is some
of our work in next-generation wearables
this is guided by my feeling that AR is
going to be useful for the masses only
if it gets down to the form factor of
eyeglasses
so why I'm enthusiastic about hololens
and some other devices that should
remain unnamed and they're good for the
factory floor and for the surgeon
they're not going to be worn for a long
time by masses and masses of people in
my humble opinion until it gets down to
where it's reasonably comfortable like
eyeglasses so this is all driven by that
assumption that in ten years or 20 years
we're going to get there as a community
and so what I want to talk to you about
are the things that we're doing to
enhance those eyeglass displays and
i glasses plays were working on putting
in lots more capability in terms of
cameras and I am used and put in aware
computing basically like digital
assistants that are more aware of where
you are and what you're doing okay so
here's a familiar sort of expert
consultation scenario that you have all
heard about so here this was taken in
our lab because we're always having
trouble with our various 3d printers and
if we ever have
Jim Haney our lab manager you know get
in an accident of being a hospital we're
in big trouble because when things go
wrong we need him to be there and it's
not good enough to talk on the phone
with him and it's not good enough to use
FaceTime because there are all kinds of
delicate things that are going wrong and
so what we envision is a future time
when there is 3d reconstruction both of
our lab and of his hospital room I hope
this never happens okay but you all
understand this now you can do this
today if you have hollow quotation
system one of my favorite systems built
right here all you familiar with this
this is a fabulous system okay the only
disadvantage is that you got to have
cameras all around the room so you could
see some of the cameras here in their
setup it's 24 cameras in each room so 8
stations in the corners and in the
Centers of each of these small rooms in
24 here and then 24 in the other guys
room okay you may need more for certain
situations less and others but that's a
lot of cameras it's not just that it's
lots of cameras it's that you need to
have it every place where you're going
to have this kind of consultation so if
the thing that went wrong in our lab was
not the 3d printer but you know that
weird color printer you know that's in
the other room well tough because he
can't go there from the hospital is that
clear so what we want to do is
do this kind of a thing anywhere you go
the assumption is that everybody is
wearing your special glasses and what
we're going to do is basically overload
that headgear with lots of cameras now
you say can you afford eight cameras or
ten cameras or whatever and my answer is
yes
not today but 10 years from now there'll
be no trouble putting in some number of
those cameras now they won't all be
working all the time but they'll work
whenever it is that the system needs it
so our first prototype which we
described a paper last year that is Mar
has eight cameras four of them outward
looking to do 3d reconstruction on the
environment and the track the user to to
look down to reconstruct the body to to
look into the face to reconstruct the
eyes and the mouth now it takes some
amount of work to do the reconstruction
of the self when you have such terrible
views basically what happens is that you
have these views looking down that you
train a CNN for with some ground truth
so we have a person walking around with
this head gear in a room which has in
our case something like six or seven
cameras and then from those six or seven
cameras we get the ground truth then we
project them back on to what they would
look like from the each one of the
downward looking cameras and then we
train the neural network for that and
that seems to work sort of well then we
put it into a full pose it's hard to
tell this is downward looking camera
because of course the pose is terrible
from that downward looking camera but
you could then get it from anywhere in
3-space so you have the estimated pose
then you put some anatomical constraints
then you put that into a parametrized
body model and then you have that to
retarget the pre scan that you have
gotten of your user finally we take the
four cameras and we construct the 3d
environment and the users pose using
state-of-the-art
structure from motion and multi
viewpoint stereo so you get wherever the
user is of course the reconstruction is
better nearer where the user is and it's
terrible when it's far away but you know
that's the way it works okay so here is
be prepared to be underwhelmed across
the department members sometimes hold
lunch even in meetings
it's restaurants
down the street are the expensive
UNC medical facilities and hospitals
in the opposite direction we reach the
center of Chavo who's Santa who's
Franklin Street and it's many shops and
restaurants there this is the end of our
tour thank you for joining me
I hope you enjoy the virtual village and
are considering visiting or starting
here farewell bye bye
so you understand what what's happening
here this 3d reconstruction there's the
audio and then that is sent to some
other place which happens to be our lab
this is offline right now and then that
person can walk around that space
wherever he wants that's why he was
walking around looking at different
places is that clear so the other thing
that I want to talk to you about is a
related project of putting a personal
assistant into this head gear now we all
know about personal assistants because I
use mine all the time you know it says
two and a half billion commands were
done by these kinds of personal
assistants of course 80% of them were
set the alarm for 15 minutes right but
now if you put your personal assistant
inside your head cue it has a
possibility of knowing the space around
you because it has access to all this
vision information and it knows
something about your user state it knows
where you're walking it knows what you
stopped it knows you were looking away
and we could also then put it into the
space visually and we think that's a big
win because then that personal assistant
in contrast to alexinnz Siri and all the
others could then motion things to you
like if you say where is you know the
reading room on this floor I know it
somewhere it will say follow me you know
it's over here so to Henry's apiece we
will turn left at robotics lab and then
turn right at conference room Palo
we filled it this is Jung from Kim's
where turn left here
okay now in fact turns left earlier
there he is and this is notice it's sort
of walking and would you like to
continue to Henry yes we will turn right
at conference room follow me all right
it's only a couple of more seconds
those are now presumably you turn right
here we have arrived would you like to
go somewhere else no thank you
so let me mention one more thing before
my time is up the displays need to be a
lot better if we're going to be wearing
these things all day and that is if you
talk to people who are doing content for
example filmmakers who make content they
will say without your prompting they're
making it 15 minutes and they say why
only 15 minutes they said after that
people sort of get queasy well why do
they get queasy it's because a lot of
different factors but latency happens to
be one of them and the other is that
you're not putting the image of the
virtual objects at the appropriate depth
when I'm holding that teapot at 20
centimeters that teapot appears to me at
1 meter or 1 and 1/2 meters and that
caused a strain not for the first minute
but if I had to do that for a long time
or that house that's virtual house
across the street should be at 50 meters
but it's really at one and a half meters
also ok so we're and so here is a
concept drawing so here you're looking
at a physical guidebook and you
looking at real buildings and you want
to have annotation both on the guidebook
saying oh this is why I marked before
though there's an interesting place to
go and by the way that happens to be
dumb Street here on the left you want
the annotation to be closed and you want
the annotation on the building to be far
away okay
so this is really difficult not just
from an optical standpoint but it's
really difficult for older people like
me because I can't adjust my focus very
well so I need to change my glasses from
near to far away well if you have all
this capability in your machine you
might as well give it your prescription
and then it knows that you know I
without my glasses see only far and I
need reading glasses then so it needs to
then correct the internal display to be
thrown at the appropriate place like
seven meters and it could also maybe if
we have a tunable lens in front
it could also correct what I'm looking
at in the real world so when I'm looking
at the guide book it will focus at the
guide book and when you're looking far
away it will correct for or far away so
here is one very small representation so
this is just our lab here in which
somebody's bicycles there and I don't
know four meters and then there's a Andy
Van Dam's book if you recognize the
computer graphics textbook and that's it
whatever it is you know 1/2 meter away
and then there's a little stamp that's
like at 20 centimeters away and now this
person here Lenny Macmillan tells me he
could see without his glasses at 7
meters so none of this stuff is in focus
but then when we when he tells us what
I'm looking at now is 1/2 meter away we
adjust the tunable lens here so that it
throws things that are 1/2 meter at 7
meters so he could see that in focus and
we further adjust a deformable
transparent membrane here so that this
display screen which is at like 10
centimetres it throws that to seven
meters away is that clear
okay so that's limited by the amount of
time that I have but oh the thing I
wanted to mention to you is now you get
says here my glasses that are useful for
you even if you never turn argumentation
on right because now I may not need to
switch between the far glasses and
reading glasses says here has all these
cameras it could tell what I'm looking
at it is tracking my eyes I'm looking at
the thing here
it focuses there I'm looking at Andy
focuses on Andy so you have all this
sensing and computing capability you
might as well use it independent of any
augmentation is that clear that's what
we think will get peep that swear I
personally think we'll get people to
wear these because even if you don't do
any augmented reality it will help you
in your daily life ok so there's another
one here in physical therapy we're
starting to work with people because
look if it records what you're doing in
the physical therapist office and then
the physical therapist says go do this
in the morning and at night for 10
minutes then it's recording it when
you're doing it the next morning
and since we're getting the joint angles
anyway when it's out of bounds it will
say you're not quite doing it right how
does it know that well they measure the
joint angles when you were in the
physical therapist office and when it
says you're not doing it right it plays
it back for you
so it's as you see right here you bent
your arms more now than you did
yesterday
ok so in summary I think my time is
about up is that right
so in summary there's lots of
possibilities you know once we get the
form factor into eyeglasses there's lots
of technologies that we could bring to
bear and there's lots of applications
either there's three of a myriad of
applications you know it's like what do
you use your cell phone for calling is
the least important thing all right
but here's what I think is the biggest
problem I hate to be a Cassandra is that
the right thing privacy
okay I think this is the showstopper
none of the technologies is a social
opera this is a showstopper why because
you know this is going to get a lot of
personal information you know if you
think that your life is not private now
think about what it would be you're
having all this recording everything all
the movements that you make okay all
your daily activities who do you see
what we see what we do this is the worst
of Big Brother okay now in fact there
are technological solutions does we
could have for example a private server
we have end-to-end encryption we have
128-bit public key encryption it's
pretty hard to break but you know what
the problem is twofold one is the
consume my view this is all my view
they're clear none of my collaborators
this is my view consumers are not
educated okay they think oh it's great
you know I will get 15% off my grocery
bill or 5% off if I just sign up for a
VIP customer and by the way I want to
share you know I want to synchronize all
my data from my phone to my laptops and
all everything okay that's going through
all some public servers okay
now public servers at some company
servers and the commercial entities and
authorities want access commercial
entities because that's how they make
their money right and authorities will
say oh we need that so that the bad guys
you know who want to do illegal things
you know we could you know catch them
were the terrorists you know we want to
be able to capture them so as a result
it's not at all clear to me that we'll
be able to solve the privacy issue so
here's my one slide conclusion 11 out at
11 okay oh I hate that okay
there's a lot of promise here the
problem is I don't know if we could
solve the privacy issues but if we can
there's lots of great things we could do
thank you
[Applause]
so we're ready also okay yeah thank you
please feed young yeah can you hear me
good that was a good decision to be sick
in no it's much quieter outside okay so
Mara asked me to talk about AR and VR at
work and I'll try to give a bit of a
hint of what we're thinking and trying
to get and we would like to have a
future where we coming in the morning to
work putting on some near eye display
and abling to do things that we couldn't
do before but if I look currently at how
people use HMDs it's mostly look like
this I'm coming in I'm putting on an
display using it for 15 minutes and then
take it off and probably continue
working as usual and there's many
reasons for that there's obviously a
blame for the quality of our current
displays their weight their resolution
focus battery power and so on but I
actually come here to talk about the
application and the software and these
are also have limitations because there
are very designed for a very specific
uses specific locations and if I want
that the display will be useful for me
throughout the day I need to be very
flexible in answering the needs so we
start to look at the value proposition
using virtual reality
and augmented reality but let me focus
first on virtual reality which seems to
be further away from work so why would
it be better to work in virtual reality
where I actually don't see the
environment around me so let's start
with our workstation most people sit
next to a table and work with computer
not very healthy but very low energetic
gesture that enables me to sit down and
work for eight hours and the first thing
most people use is the mouse and
keyboard so we looked at this ability
can VR let us take this environment with
us so wherever I go I can put on a
headset and I have my office around me
and I could work like I used to
would I be able to use office the same
way in VR so if I look at keyboards
which are the most common way that
people know how to enter text whether
these are physical keyboards that give
us a haptic feedback or touch keyboards
that you can find on tablets can we use
them in VR which wasn't immediately
clear how to use that but nowadays as we
see the technology progressed we see
more and more devices that enable us for
example capacitive sensing keyboards or
tracking visually tracking the hands
that enable us to see both the keyboard
as well as our hands and how good are we
in typing that for example view is
typically limited relative to a natural
okay and disconnect us from reality and
say the keyboard and our hands are not
where they are but they wherever I'm
looking at so this way I can disconnect
I myself not a touch typist though I can
see the way that I type wherever I'm
looking at the document also why do we
need to see our hands maybe there's
other way representation that enable us
to work better so we tried out different
ways that we can represent our hands
from not rendering at hands at all just
what keys are being pressed to yeah okay
so that's what you see there on the
corner to getting just a video feed of
what we do which suppose to be the
closest we can have for real life but
still wearing an HMV to modeling the
motions that we do of the hands as 3d
objects and finally just the tip of our
fingers touching the keyboards by the
way any idea which one is the best do
people know what would you say okay so
what we saw was when we looked at the
quality the the speed the errors the
preference of people what was surprise
to us was that people actually like very
minimalistic approach like the tip of
the fingers while a very complete
representation like 3d hands were not
that good even small differences between
what the the 3d hands are doing and what
we do generate some kind of uncanny
valley which reduces our speed then we
look at the computer for example the
keyboard nobody says that the keyboard
had to look like it looks today when we
can change the environment around us so
maybe we can generate the additional
value in VR by changing how the keyboard
is for example I could change the
language easily or if I need to add
additional contextual characters like
putting an omelet in Germany
when I press a button I can immediately
show options around it that we can use
we can have shortcuts without learning
where they are or use the window manager
instead of alt tab jump directly to the
application on the keyboard and
basically what we can do is we can look
at the keyboard in two dimensions one is
what is the functionality that we're
getting are we pressing one button and
getting one functionality or maybe we
can press a group of buttons or maybe
even have a mapping like touch surface
that wherever we touch in the keyboard
it will have a different functionality
and also how we represent the keyboard
visually to people whether it is we're
changing a single button or changing the
geometry for example unifying three
buttons - one big one or even do things
such as sliders or in this case we
enables people to put in password
privately by having a private shuffling
inside the VR while people see you type
and cannot recover the password and
here's another example where we use the
keyboard as a touch surface just for
gaming so wherever the hammer hits the
keyboard we we know whether we hit that
whack-a-mole and here's an example where
a person can actually okay can actually
type input continuous position along a
video and if he for example press two
buttons which get an intermediate
position so that was about our
workstation but we're not just sitting
in the workstation we're going to
meeting we're going around the office
and we wanted to see if we can actually
make the application be flexible enough
to deal with the environment around us
sometimes I I go to a big room like this
sometimes I maybe sit in a small room
and application should be flexible to
deal with that and we did that mostly in
a are nowadays we are expanding also to
VR of looking at around and the
environment and then giving some rules
from the designer we can change the
application to fit that specific room
for example here is a game of a speed
racer where the track is different
between different rooms because the
geometry is different but difficulty of
the game and other aspects that we
needed from the application is the same
and by the way if I wish I heard your
talk before because I would give another
page that we did something specifically
that for the privacy where there's a lot
of things that we learn on the fly in
the device but we don't send the
information back what we actually send
these multiple options toward the device
and the device decide what to do
according to that and nowadays for
example products like unity are
following things such as flair to
incorporate that into application for
augmented reality now let almost running
out of time so I'll just go for the
total wild what if I want to right now
where the head-up display and just start
walking around the building walking
outside and you might ask why would I do
that I'm already in virtual reality and
I don't care where I am so there's
different motivations for doing that for
example think of I right now want to
visit a remote site I put on a VR
headset and suddenly I'm at the remote
site and people over there grant walk
with me they may be using an AR display
to see me in their lab or site and as I
walk I want to be able not to hit any
people around here or chair or table
but still feel like I'm over there can I
do that it's a bit weird it's a if you
can imagine someone walking in the
corridors with a bluetooth earpiece
talking to unknown person on the phone
this is someone walking through the
corridors with eyes blocked and talking
and interacting with people that we
don't see but it's sort of the same kind
of semantics and obviously games I could
suppose I want to do a multi-user games
on a large environment and unfortunately
I don't own an arena can I be able to do
that in the real environment and still
not endanger myself or maybe I want to
go for tourism and again this is really
weird I already go to an archeological
site and I put the VR and block myself
from it why would I do that because I'm
coming with other people and I can hear
I can smell I can test all around but
suddenly the people that the tourists
are wearing togas and the cars are
chariots and I feel like I'm in that
period then whenever I take off the hmd
I'm back in current time so we have
several systems that we built one of
them was called V Roemer which the idea
was how can we play a game that will be
on not on my slide okay
that's interesting let me just that
okay do I have it here bear with me one
second all right so let me take it okay
so suppose someone wants to play a game
in a big environment and lets me and I
don't hear myself either okay
so someone is walking in a in a in a in
a game and he's actually in an
environment full of people and you need
to be walking there and still be safe so
how can we do that we have a script that
we have to follow which is in the game
we cannot invent that on the fly and on
the other hand this environment could
change all the time someone might bring
in a cart and block my way or open the
door or close the door so what we do we
actually look at the event or the
experience as a graph we have nodes that
we need to go through to complete a
story and while each node by itself is
well-defined we give Springs between
those nodes and those Springs are paths
that we generate on the fly as we walk
around an environment so I'm putting on
and headset I'm in a dungeon I walking
around I need to go and find the
treasure if son leader my way is blocked
then I can see some event happening and
a door opens here or maybe a pile of
rocks fall here and blocks my way and
eventually when I see that there is
enough space to do a node that I need to
render then suddenly I see a house that
I can go in and take the treasure and so
on and so we had people walking around
our building walking around the campus
trying to do that and I'm it's a bit
weird that I don't have the video I hope
I'll find it by the end
I don't want to take too much time okay
thank you a young so yeah it's kind of
interesting I want to highlight two
things from a young stock just now and
one is you know there are multiple ways
we can be smart about their privacy so
that Henry was talking about before and
and the other one is that using the
inside out tracking systems and cameras
that are looking outside we can start
having object avoidance some people
actually walk in through a building
inside another setup either be a game or
any other type of content okay so let me
just one second
introduce the next speaker so we are now
gonna move into the part of the session
in which we focus about fidelity because
we've seen devices by Henry Fuchs we've
seen all these different applications
from a Yale and how these moves into the
wild really like walking down the street
what does it feel how can you avoid some
people that might come into your
obstacles but they what will make this
safe for you to do that is the level of
fidelity in which you achieve in inside
the brutal environments and also for
productivity because you need this
critical accuracy for things so I went
invite Sarah Kramer from University of
Utah to provide her view on fidelity for
VR and productivity thank you
yes.can there's that you can hear me
okay okay great okay thank you I'm
really happy to be here today as Mark
said I I'm Sarah creamer gear I am a
psychology professor at the University
of Utah and my area of study is in
visual perception and spatial cognition
and I've been studying these topics in
both real and virtual environments for a
number of years for me when I think
about the use of virtual and augmented
reality for spatial cognition I think of
the R&A are as both an opportunity and
as a challenge and the opportunity is
that with virtual environments
especially immersive virtual
environments we can manipulate
environment based and body based cues in
ways that are really difficult or
sometimes impossible to do in the real
world but at the same time we can
maintain ecological validity well we
have people perceiving and acting in
realistic immersive spaces where they
can interact as if it were the real
world so ideally this balance of control
in experimental paradigms and realism
could help us to to really make progress
in understanding the basic mechanisms
understanding spatial cognition how we
understand spaces around us but the
challenge is that we would argue that
the utility of virtual environments
increases for research and for
applications with the likelihood that
people will perceive and act in the
virtual space in the same way that they
were act in the real world okay so we
call this concept perceptual fidelity
how closely can we match people to
actions in the virtual space to the real
space
okay and if they're matched closely then
we can think that we have some high
level of perceptual fidelity so one of
the challenges that we faced in the
study of virtual environments over a
number of years is this pervasive
finding that virtual spaces seem to be
perceived as smaller than what's
intended so they're perceived as kind of
these spaces are perceived as compressed
even when the virtual spaces are matched
exactly in geometry to the real world
okay so this could be a problem for both
research and applications that rely on
perception of absolute scale okay so
perceiving absolute size and distance is
critical for many applications such as
architectural design or training and
simulation or even navigation kind of
assistance so um I have taken a real
interdisciplinary approach to the study
of perceptual fidelity with my
colleagues in computer science at Utah
and at Vanderbilt and other places where
we come at it from kind of a dual
perspective in that we're trying to
address this applied problem of creating
virtual spaces that are as effective as
they can be right so that people will
act in them as if they were in the real
world
but in doing this research we've also
gained a lot of insights into the
mechanisms that underlie visual space
perception and spatial cognition such as
for example we've looked at the
influence of feedback as you move
through a space and how that leads to
visual motor calibration or changing
this relationship between perception and
action and we've looked at the role of
the visual body and scaling space by
putting avatars into spaces so how do we
measure the perception of the scale of
the environment that people perceive
well what we've argued is that there are
many ways to do this and you can ask
people about how big things look and
kind of how much they feel present in
the environment but what we think is a
strong measure is to look at people's
actions okay so we've looked at the
measurement of
fidelity in terms of action and one
example is using a task that we call
blind walking that's been shown in many
over decades in the real world to be a
really good valid measure of distance
perception so in this type of task it's
called a visually directed action where
you may look at a target and then in the
environment close your eyes and walk the
distance to that target okay so what we
know is that people are very good at
doing this in the real world up to maybe
about 20 or more 20 or so meters and the
idea is that we're very good at
dynamically updating our position in
space as we move the other measure that
I'll talk about in more detail is a
measure of perceived affordances so this
is a question that we asked an observer
is it possible to act on the space okay
so this is just an example here showing
if you're presented with an aperture
that you could possibly pass through you
make a decision is it possible to pass
the route to pass through that based on
your own body dimensions okay so we can
use these both these types of action
based measures to make comparisons
between what people do in the virtual
world and what people do in real world
spaces to get a sense of the level of
perceptual fidelity so here's just an
example of some some work that we and
many others have done on distance
perception in virtual environments we're
typically using this measure of blind
walking which we know that people are
close to accurate at doing in the real
world on average across many different
studies in virtual environments we've
found that people underestimate the
distance by walking okay so they'll walk
about 70% of the actual distance and
this has been shown in many different
studies but the reason I also bring this
up is today say that some of the
challenges that we've we experienced may
change with changing technologies so
this is a study that we did a couple
years ago that compared the same exact
task
same exact virtual environment but with
two just different head mounted displays
so the first one I showed you is the the
traditional n vis hmd that we had used
for many years and found about you know
that people are arrested showing about
seventy percent accuracy and then when
we compare that to people doing this
judgment wearing this was the oculus DK
- a couple years ago we see that people
are more accurate now they're walking
about 90 percent of the distance and
this now has been replicated by a number
of different labs with a number of
different of the new commodity level
head mounted displays so some of this
distance compression that we saw for
maybe you know 10 or more years with the
old technologies seems to be going away
a little bit okay so we need to kind of
adapt our questions and challenges to
these new technologies so this brings me
to thinking about augmented reality so
we've become interested in measuring the
perceptual fidelity of AR in the similar
way that we've looked at doing these
measurements in VR so in augmented
reality again we may face different
challenges and different opportunities
because here's a case where now people
are in a real world environment and
their experience in the real world but
now we superimpose graphics over that
world and we want to ask the question
similarly do people perceive spatial
locations distances sizes in the same
way in AR as they would do if they have
completely real world so to do this
we've been using this measure of
perceived affordances and as I mentioned
before this is the idea of asking people
about judgments for their action
capabilities now this idea of
affordances came from JJ Gibson in his
last book in 1979 where he defined
affordances as the action possibilities
in an environment which are directly
related to an observers capabilities
okay so it's the idea what the for
dances it's not just what's in the
environment but you're making a decision
of those features in the environment
with respect to your own body your own
body dimensions your own body
capabilities so back to the doorway
doorway is passable only if it's wider
than the widest part of your body
okay so otherwise you're gonna bump your
shoulders when you walk into that
aperture unless you turn your body okay
so we can ask about affordances and many
different types of actions passing
through you could ask affordance about
about within reaching or grasping space
so an apple may be graspable only if it
fits within the span of your hand
okay so we're relating the environment
to your own body and we can do this both
within the virtual environment and the
real world and make direct comparisons
so this is what we did in a series of
studies and we're still continuing these
with different types of affordances and
different questions but one thing we
were interested in is to test different
affordances that rely on different body
dimensions and capabilities as well as
different regions of space or different
scales of distances okay so I'm going to
tell you about just quickly a study that
looked at passing through which I've
mentioned before so this is looking at
an aperture that's you know a number of
meters away from you and then another
type of affordance which is stepping
over a gap okay so this is now a
different type of action but it's also a
different region of space this is a
space that's right at your body okay so
we want to see if people how people
judge affordances in AR when we have
these differences and whether this might
interact with some of the the features
of the technology we're using the
hololens here so just to give you a
little bit more about the method of
using affordances here's an example so
we have one of our graduate students
grant who's the picture is on the top
image and he's wearing the hololens
and then you see on the bottom and
bottom image what's he's what he is
seeing so there's two virtual poles and
these poles can be presented at
different distances away from him and at
different widths okay so on every trial
he needs to look at the width between
those two poles and decide whether yes
or no
he's answers can I pass through or not
okay and so then what we do is we we
have a whole set of trials that
have these AR poles and then we have a
whole nother set of trials that have
real-world poles and the person is
always standing in the same real-world
lab okay so everything's kind of
controlled except though the only
difference is whether they're seeing AR
objects or real-world objects and we get
these yes or no responses and then we
take the point at which the person
switches from saying yes I could pass
through to no I could not okay and
that's their crossover point and we
scale that we may take a ratio of that
to their actual shoulder width okay so
we can say are they making these
judgments relative you know to their own
body size and then also in this study we
had people walk using the blind walking
measure to the distance to the poles
because we were interested to see their
distance perception and in this ere
context as well okay so the take-home
message is that we saw very similar
performance with real-world polls and AR
polls so there's no significant
difference here green bars are they are
gray bars or the real world both in the
blind walking task which is just
presented as a the ratio of distance
walk to the actual distance and they're
passing through judgment which is their
crossover point in relation to their own
actual passing through okay so this is
good news that we find that using the
hololens people are actually able to
judge affordances to virtual objects in
the same way that they judge affordances
to real objects but this story actually
changed a little bit for our next
affordance judgment so this is now
stepping over a gap and you can see in
these images people either have a real
piece of material that's a different gap
with sin right at their feet or here's
our observer looking down at her feet
and seeing the virtual gap okay so again
similar on every trial the gap changes
in width and the person just has to say
could I step over that gap taking the
largest step that is possible without
running or jumping or without moving
their back foot off of the ground and we
take that crossover point again when
they say
yes I could step over the gap - no I
could not and divide that by their
actual largest step okay so we get ratio
again to what they could actually do and
we're directly comparing what they do
with a real-world stimulus versus the AR
gap
okay so then in this case we found that
people underestimated their capability
in AR compared to the real world so we
know from other states we've done and
what's in the literature and affordances
that people tend to overestimate their
capability to step over a gap in the
real world so what we're what we're
interested in is not so much the
absolute accuracy but how does their
accuracy compared to the real world okay
so the real words are standard and in AR
they're under estimating the question is
why we have some thoughts about this
that relate to the limitations of the
field of view in the hololens so when
you think about it if something's
farther away that AR more of that AR
object is going to fit within the field
of view but here in the gap which is
right at their feet
and you look down and you have a pretty
narrow field of view both vertical and
horizontal field of view in the hololens
then you only see a very small portion
of that graphics like in every kind of
view that you take so what people have
to do is really rotate their head and
integrate these different pieces of the
virtual gap together and it could be
that that makes them perceive that it's
bigger and that they're less capable of
stepping over a larger gap so so it's
possible that the perceptual fidelity of
AR in terms of affordances is influenced
by the space of the action that we are
talking about and that again interacts
with potentially the technology that if
we had a wider field of view maybe we
wouldn't see the limitation in the near
space it's also very likely that the
properties of the AR object matter such
as its shape its texture one of the
things that Bobby's going to talk a
little bit more about is the importance
of shadows and the importance of being
able to perceive that target as grounded
as a really
to the ground so there are many
different factors involved in likely
involved in this perceptual fidelity of
error objects that we still need to
continue to explore so to conclude what
I would argue is that we can think about
mediated environments on a continuum
from completely real world to AR objects
to completely virtual world as having
the potential to advance space spatial
research and applications but in order
to do that it's really important to
evaluate perceptual fidelity in terms of
what humans can do in terms of how
people actually act and compare that
performance to the real world and use
the real world as a standard what we've
been seeing is that there's more
flexibility in AR environments where we
can still have the real world but add
augmented stimuli and features into the
environment but also challenges for the
perception of realism of those augmented
reality objects and Bobby bodenheimer
will expand on that a little bit more in
some of the research that we're doing
together
so thank you thank you Sarah yeah I
think it's very interesting to start
thinking about okay we can beyond
productivity but how good do we need to
be and what type of sort of errors will
this generate our nest egg speaker is
Bobby bodenheimer from Vanderbilt okay
thank you I'm glad to be here thanks for
inviting me
there we go and great
yeah I'm Bobby bodenheimer from
Vanderbilt University and I work closely
with Sarah as she said so I my talk is
somewhat of a continuation of hers I'm
going to talk about some of the
challenges we face in trying to get high
perceptual fidelity in the augmented
reality
so just to recap although I don't think
we need to do much of that
just what perceptual fidelity is is one
our interactions with our augmented
reality objects to match interactions
with real world objects if they do that
we would say we have high perceptual
fidelity if they don't we would have low
perceptual fidelity this is a concept
that has been developed in virtual
reality and it's typically studied with
affordances as Sarah was talking about
so here you have the passing through
affordance that she talked about people
are passing through in the real world
the poles are gonna get closer together
at some point they would go single file
or they would been to face each other
and become narrower if you do that with
vert them sorry if you do that with
avatars you would want those crossover
points to be the same all right so
that's the concept of perceptual
fidelity again to recap in a nutshell
and I am going to limit there are many
ways of doing augmented reality right
there are many different display
modalities for augmented reality you can
have tablet augmented reality you can
have a number of different devices and
people work on different devices some of
those people are in this room I'm gonna
limit my discussion of augmented reality
optical see-through head-mounted
displays like the hololens like the
magic leap okay and so i'm going to talk
about the challenges associated with
those specific devices those devices
that are available to the consumer today
okay so I think if you had different
devices like tablet based augmented
reality you would have different
challenges for getting perceptual
fidelity through those devices and it
would be sort of a whole different
ballgame but I think the challenge is
with those devices
the hololens and so on are going to be
challenges associated with brightness
transparency of the augmented reality
objects limited field of view and the
ability that the rendering engine can
only add light to the scene okay and
we'll see how that if is affected is
affecting perceptual fidelity I want to
talk about three specific examples in my
remaining remarks all right
so those are perception of depth and
gaps continuing on sort of continuing on
with what Sarah said and so let's
consider example from VR so the
perception of depth
anyone who's done VR for any amount of
time knows that when you are presented
with depth and vr presented with the
illusion that you're at height that
becomes a very compelling experience
here's a classic example of this from
the University of North Carolina of a
Pitt room and when you're presented like
standing right here looking down your
heart rate increases you begin to break
out in sweat and and so on because
you're afraid you're gonna fall even
though you're standing on a flat floor
like this okay or maybe as they did at
North Carolina you you're standing on a
slightly raised elevation where you can
just feel like there's a little Ridge
right there that enhances the illusion
but it's not completely necessary to get
that okay and this is a classic Pitt
room classic paper explaining these
effects okay and everyone who does VR
demos has one of these in their little
library that they pull out when high
school students come through this is
ours okay and there's a gap in the
middle there and you get really great
effects when people try to walk out
through there their balance is affected
and everything and we've done affordance
studies in these environments and we've
shown that if you want behavior to match
what they do stepping off of heights in
the real world like stepping off of this
table maybe a little lower stepping off
of that chair you need to
have people endowed with a full body
self avatar and then the fidelity of the
virtual environment matches that of the
real world very well ok so you have high
perceptual fidelity and if you don't
have a full body self avatar everything
is out of whack ok so those are examples
of from virtual reality of getting high
perceptual fidelity and having good
perception of depth and so on now let's
think about the case with augmented
reality you can create an illusion of
depth in the floor with augmented
reality this is an example of doing it
in the hololens and people will you you
can create this illusion and it does
look like there's a pit in the floor and
we've done studies here to show that
people's behavior will be affected by
this but it's not going to be as
compelling as in virtual reality ok
nobody is gonna break out in a sweat
nobody's going to be terrified of
falling in the pit here so what we can
show is that people's gap judgment in
the sense of what Sarah was talking
about their ability to judge whether
they would step across a pit of various
widths there is affected by the depth of
the gap and let me give you an example
so this is what it looks like more or
less it doesn't look quite this good in
the real world through the hololens but
that's that's sort of what that depth
looks like in the hololens and you can
see there's a little bit of transparency
there and so on and this is just gonna
replay so I'll let you see it one more
time and that's one and a half meters
deep so what you can see here is is it
compared to the step that they would
take normally in the real world the the
depth of the pit is affecting what their
judgment is but
and the deeper the pit goes the more
it's affecting it but it's not a
compelling illusion so this has we have
some fidelity and augmented reality but
it's not a great amount of fidelity I
would say and this is because this that
you can see the floor through the
illusion you can tell you have this
limited field of view you have to sort
of space things together so there are
limits because of the current technology
to producing a true high fidelity
illusion in augmented reality here the
second example I want to talk about is
shadows it's been known for a long time
that shadows are essential cues to
getting the 3d position and shape of
objects da Vinci knew that everybody's
known it since then and there's been a
lot of work on rendering algorithms and
computer graphics put to getting shadows
correct okay but let's think about
shadows in augmented reality with these
technologies are hard oh and here's an
example right I forgot about this this
is an example so these cubes are in the
same place but obviously the shadow is
pin is showing you that it's pinned to
the floor so when you put a shadow in in
the example it becomes pin to the to the
plane there and it becomes perceptually
obvious that it's pinned to the plane
and there are other cues that you could
put in the scene like inner reflections
and so on that would perceptually pin it
as well or better but I'm just
concentrating on shadows here all right
so rendering shadows in AR is more
difficult because we can only add light
to the scene and here's an example of
how we're doing it we did not invent
this technique we sort of came up with
it but other people invented it and if
you try to figure out who invented it
first you get into a morass of problems
so I don't actually know who thought of
this technique first it's kind of one of
those things like the blend line
clipping algorithm was sort of presented
first and he was the first that wrote
about it but I don't even
no the first person write about it was a
lot of people thought about it perhaps
what you do is you render a gray shadow
mask here and then you put a light
penumbra around it so that your visual
system enhances the contrast here and
makes it look like a shadow okay and
that's sort of the best you can do in
the hololens and this is the way we do
these images in my lab to convince to
remind ourselves that we're seeing them
through the hololens as we leave the
cursor in the hololens on there so this
is through the hololens and you can see
that this looks okay but you can see the
contour of the penumbra out there and
the problem with this is that it's
affected by the texture of the
underlying surface so this was done on a
wooden surface if we change the surface
to a tablecloth a checkered tablecloth
then the penumbra goes away to some
extent but the transparency issue of the
cube comes through and you can you can
see that we're getting placement
information so in this case the image on
the right the cube is actually above the
tablecloth and the shadow is giving you
that information but it doesn't look
great okay so shadows are a real problem
with current technology because of this
ability to only add light to the scene
and obviously the transparency is is
causing us problems just because of the
way we don't have enough brightness and
and so on in our in our displays and
then the third and final thing that I
want to talk about just very briefly is
passability
sera talked about possibility I want to
consider a slightly more realistic
example of possibility and talk about it
in the context of the narrow field of
view of our current AR devices here's an
example of two walls and your your your
task perhaps is to judge whether you can
go through them and then to walk through
them and this looks pretty good I mean
these are AR walls you can tell they're
AR
because you can see the you can see the
wall behind them the real world wall
behind them now the problem here is is
that this view is from a specific
perspective in the real world and you
make this view and then you start
walking towards the walls the AR walls
and all of a sudden something unexpected
will happen they will go out of view of
the eye box of the hololens and they
will disappear
because now the field of view is there
outside of the field of view of where
you can render graphics and that's very
unexpected to the naive user and what
does the naive user do they stop and
they look around right so does it change
their behavior well this is something
we're currently looking at I don't know
the answer to that and then they can
walk up to where the AR walls are and
they can look and oh there's a wall
there and oh there's a wall there but
what do they do about that and that's
not the way that real world walls behave
they don't suddenly disappear and then
you go up and suddenly they're there or
not so this is a real problem for us in
terms of the the field of view in in
sort of act in sort of affordances where
we're actually acting out the affordance
judgment instead of just making a clear
a passive judgment about it okay and so
this is where the the field of view of
the hololens is is is a problem and so
the takeaway messages that I would like
you to take home from this talk are that
the state of the art and optical
see-through augmented reality displays
is improving and it's improving rapidly
and people in this room are working on
that but having said that many of the
problems for high perceptual fidelity
are difficult and it's difficult to
foresee that those problems are going to
be fixed certainly at the consumer level
in the near future
and so what we're going to be faced with
and what I work on is fixing and
creating software enhancements software
tricks to leverage perception to raise
sometimes artificially the perceptual
fidelity of our AR environments so that
we can get away with doing what we want
to do and convincing you that augmented
reality is real and figuring out what
those software enhancements is is
challenging alright and so that's my
talk thank you for your attention
[Applause]
ok
thank you very much we can have now the
panelists come over here if you prefer
to have a smaller chairs we can also
have a smaller chairs yes - good yeah
this one's very interesting Bobby I
think of course to go into production or
the productivity challenge in inside the
bitter reality I think it should be fine
it's ok if we don't have you know it's
ok I'll put the Q&A ok so if somebody
has questions we are gonna have a mic
over there and so I think there are a
few things that I want to summarize
about this couple of talks one is we're
talking about wearable devices they have
challenges both in privacy and
infidelity that we need to address in
order to achieve productive scenarios
and applications and I feel many of
these challenges are opportunities for
both Hardware creation and so for
creation and I think that
maybe start a discussion I think there
was a hand over there no yeah good we
got a winner time I'm just gonna put on
the background these is live with the
the productivity examples
hi Evan Zimmer from the University of
Minnesota I'd like to start with a
somewhat pessimistic question given the
the interesting results of that Sara
showed about the distance estimation
being less compressed with modern head
mounted displays I'm wondering how
suspicious do we need to be about like
the 30 years worth of perceptual and
cognitive studies and empirical results
that we have in the VR community with
old technology is there a need now to
replicate ever all the work that's been
done and following up on that what does
it mean for researchers who are doing
that type of perceptual work when
there's now that the pace of
technological advancements much faster a
new higher field-of-view lower latency
display could come out the next year and
then suddenly render all those studies
and phenomenons that you're looking at
oh never mind it's no longer a problem
anymore okay I think I'll take this one
yeah in fact this is very interesting
because I recently reviewed this paper
that it's gonna be accepted
congratulations to the answers but they
were complaining that because in
inverter reality you don't have a good
binocular perception basically any type
of visual motor coordination that you
can the mother it does is not
transferable to reality so that was kind
of a very interesting premise and I
think you know that will be solved over
time and I think Sarah can talk a bit
more about you know how I've seen the
distance estimation has changed with new
devices but you know I think it's it's
an evolving field so we will see a lot
of that of devices getting better which
I'm very glad to see but maybe sorry
you know it's hard for me to say that
like the last 15 years work that I did
is like should be down the drain right
now that these these new technologies
came out like I think there's still some
worth in it in the sense that we've also
argued that that studying studying how
this distance compression are like kind
of these effects in virtual rooms can
kind of help us in understanding the
basic perceptual mechanisms the basic
information that's used in the real
world even so for example we can look at
a vittoria Vitara in the virtual
environment even in the old HMDs and the
envis we would get more accurate
distance judgments so people so we can
say that then people use their visual
body to scale that space right so we can
think of examples where we were trying
to chase down the applied problem but in
fact that helped us understand what
information people are using in the real
world to judge judge space so I would
say but then it also is a good question
to say like you know are we gonna just
be chasing the technology should we
should we make a big deal about like the
10 % distance compression that we see in
the oculus or the vibe because now you
know the next generation that comes out
maybe we won't even see that maybe it
will be the way issues solved in with
think it's even more like imagine you're
driving you're driving in continental
Europe do you drive on the right side
you go to the UK you drive on the left
side and you can have both modalities
and assume both modalities or even if
you are speaker of multiple languages
you're able to compartmentalize so I
guess you could learn that inverter
reality this is how perception works and
this is how perception works outside the
reality and then just have them up in I
have a slightly different answer than
Sarah's and I've worked in this field as
well but I think it's I think that it's
important because it's science and it's
evolving knowledge and I think to fixate
on the specific devices too much is to
miss the broader point when I got into
the when I got into this work 15
years ago let's say I mean people were
concentrating on is it accommodation
vergence mismatch that was causing
distance compression I think the answer
to that is no is it the weight of the
hmd that's causing it I think the answer
to that is yes what does that tell us we
need lighter HMDs is it the field of
view of the hmd that's causing it the
answer to that is I think yes we need
wider field of view HMDs is it other
factors that are causing it the answer
to that is still yes it limited field of
view and and weight of the H and D don't
account for all of it so I think that
but but you know we narrow it we
eliminate some factors you you check off
the marks for other factors it tells you
how to design better HMDs so I think
that's what you have to focus on and not
the specifics of well the dk2 is better
than the in vis sx60 which is worse than
something else and so on and so forth so
that's I think the way I look at it
let's move to the next question and I'll
ask the rest so I think Joel was then
and and then we'll have an even them hi
Joel Collin famous are actually it's a
kind of a follow-on question to the last
topic great do you think that there's
anything that this especially in VR
because I agree with you but AR it's
just the the field of view is so narrow
it's almost worthless for to study at
this point but if VR do you think that
there's any correlation between this
effect and perhaps lack of calibration
for the or lack of accurate calibration
for the user specific inter ocular
distance and how that might also play
with the design of the HMT yes Aram
Bobby well I mean we're we've actually
been interested in that question very
recently because we've been we've
started to test children in
HTC vive and the vive IPD only goes down
to like 61 millimeters and a child's IPD
is going to be like 50 or less maybe
even so we've started so subjectively
we've run a bunch of children in VR and
have had no one complained that the
images looked blurry or that that they
couldn't see depth or something like
this but at the same time we haven't
objectively measured is their distance
perception biased in some way especially
for near distances so we're starting to
look at that we're starting to measure
more specifically are the range of IPs
that we have and see if we can see if
the mismatch predicts distance judgments
but so so there's some possibility we
did some work years ago where we did a
controlled study where we set the IPD to
their measure we measured the
participants IBD or we just used a
standard value or we even have no we had
by ocular vision the same image to both
eyes and we found no difference in the
distance compression using the envis you
know probably ten years ago but that's
really interesting yeah any difference
yeah so it's hard to do you think that's
because we get the depth through a
parallax rather than yeah I think part
of it is these distances are outside of
the you know close space where we're
binocular disparity shouldn't matter
right so we're looking at distances that
are three four five eight meters away
and so one thing that we want to look at
in this new IPD study is like really
looking at within a meter or two
distances compared to farther distances
so you did the IPD study but only for
things that are pretty far away not the
stepping over that's right we didn't we
did it for distance judgments that were
like starting at about three or four
meters okay I'm the police so many
questions I'll just select a few so have
you tried doing these various
measurements with a faked field of view
in the real world no headgear
limited field of view through some kind
of little cardboard cutout
yeah and compared that against what the
head mount gives you what do you find we
people are accurate in the real world
until you get really really really much
smaller than you would even think so
that would say that field of view isn't
all that important something else
because that's what that was my paper
that we did and then Bobby do did a very
extensive study with the vibe oculus and
vis-a-vis yeah and found in VR that the
field of view mattered but in the real
we found in the real world we restricted
field of view and as long as we let
people rotate their heads they were
accurate if we had it we had one
condition where we had a neck brace on
and they couldn't rotate their head and
they showed distance compression so but
in the in VR you can always rotate your
head right so so we had claimed it
wasn't field of view at that time you
know the new VR the new consumer-level
HMDs seem to be showing something a
little bit different so second question
there seems to be a variation with the
the age of the equipment is there any
prediction possible based on going back
ten years and moving forward in the tech
to see what we could expect next
well the gap just narrow asymptotically
it's a good question it could I mean it
could be that were the best we could be
right now right like with the survive
let's cope we're getting bit there no
it's getting better and then I think a
our devices have a ways to go right so
would hope for some improvement alright
last question Oh Randy Andy Andy we have
four more people the last one okay dude
you can do another one just the last one
Randy Pausch started a lot of this work
many years ago by looking at slope
measurements
I noticed none of you did that then that
seemed to have a big difference between
what you experienced in VR and the real
world have any of you looked at slope
measurements I haven't liked slant of
measuring inclination yeah some I
haven't directly either but some some
have you know and I think that there's
some distortions but not with the new
HMDs though so that would be yeah okay
please good afternoon everyone I'm Jacob
checkelsky I'm with the University of
Alabama and first of all I would like to
start by thanking the the panel for the
very interesting discussions I really
enjoy it and I'm happy to be part of
this session now I'm very passionate
about augmented in virtual reality
it's two topics that I think that I mean
the technologies can be transformative
and make a really big impact on our
society and I've been working on them
for the past almost two years and I have
a remark that I would like to ask the
panel to comment upon and so I would
like to share it with you first so in
the late summer of 2017 maybe the fall
I had my background is in communication
systems coding of data how data is
delivered over networks so I had these
striking observations I mean these
technologies are very exciting and the
impact could be truly achieved if we can
deploy them with actual content
representing repair machine in a
wireless manner where the data is one
location and the user is somewhere else
but then you know I made the observation
you know that our network systems as of
today and even those network systems of
the future would not be able to support
the required data rates and latencies
that we would need to deliver this data
to a remote user for instance in a
remote setting a care setting slide
short like where a firefighter may want
to go to a remote site wegg's
to examine it remotely and so forth and
so to make sure the time was not going
nuts I intended most of the events or
venues in this in the system's areas
she's infocomm sick home and i talked to
other researches about this apparent
bottleneck that you know we have even
more bigger challenges ahead of us to
solve to to enable its potential and
there was an agreement in a you know in
a growing community that there are many
interesting technical aspects to be
solved there and so the comments that we
have observed so far and all these
challenges that were shared in the panel
they're very interesting and you know
understandably most of the work that in
this area has come so far from the
computer vision and usability studies
and so forth where all these challenges
are appear but they're even bigger
challenges ahead as I said because I'll
given one example if you wanna send okay
um just carrying a little bit so I
understand your questions about how we
scale networks to provide this type of
remote applications I think maybe
Henry's a good complete can I just
complete my thought so solving this
challenge would require integration of
emerging technologies in a way that has
not been done before because just
expecting the next generation of 5g
networks to solve this alone would not
do it so there is a need for several
technology such as edge computing
sending data using visible light or
millimeter wave and more efficient ways
of representing the data to be
integrated in an end-to-end manner to
resolve this question this was my point
okay good
thank you a yell or Henry if you want to
answer regarding how you see you know
content distribution or right there's
certainly lots of technologies that
we're going to need much more than we
have right now and the content
transmission I think is one that we have
in face yet and I think that's because
the other more primitive technologies
are not good enough yet so even if
somebody solved if somebody magically
gave us a hundred gigabits per second to
my home I couldn't use it because the
rest of the ecosystem is not there yet
so I think that as a worldwide community
we're solving
various problems as they come up I agree
with you that communication is a lot a
lot but I think that's what you
identified for example field of view I
think it's the biggest problem in AR
today and told if you could only solve
it for us I think he's doing it already
okay wait a second do you need a
microphone because this is being
recorded but you have to make it like
super short because it's called a figure
you know so the some of the numbers are
really like striking so if we want to
serve multiple users the rates that you
need to to use I mean your network to
support go beyond 10 of terabytes per
second per square meter
well how much data you want to transfer
because we have been using photon server
for local multiplayer in VR and you know
it works pretty well and and I think
these things will scale I agree with
Henry and also look at other factors
such as the dependency between what
multiple users sees and dependency on
location and things like that that you
can use to really lower okay that's all
for today and thank you very much
everyone for coming I also want to
highlight that the Victorian ta'rhonda
who's also an expert on distance
compression is here so if you have more
questions maybe C's talk about the
slopes or other questions that you had
so regarding fertility and thank you
very much everyone thank you
you